Her low freak bitches.
I've noticed that ever since I started making money.
Guys sexually want to dominate me,
choke me,
spit on me.
Oh,
I've gotten spit on.
That did happen in my twenties when I was broke though.
When I was 20 and my brain broke,
I just wanted to cuddle me and contact and grab your face and we're done.
Now that I have money,
I'm getting choked.
I mean spanked.
I gotta I gotta I gotta tell me what this is.
I had a guy put his four fingers in my mouth and just leave them there for like
two minutes.
What's that?
Wash your hands.
Have a seven year old.
She's sick because she touches things and then touches her mouth.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
just learn so much about you.
You could never be single by the way today.
You better make this marriage work forever because you're not gonna be able to
handle it.
Cause the hands in the mouth.
It's very unsanitary out there,
Joe.
Oh,
hands on.
Well,
I'm not worried about myself.
So he stuck his hand in my mouth and it was,
I've spent every night,
the comedy store for 10 years.
My immune system is on point.
I know I've got a thousand hands at night.
And I think that sharing a microphone with 3,300 road comics every night does a
number on your immune system.
I never get sick.
Never gets it.
Yeah.
She can hold those hands.
Does it or just believe that sharing a microphone with Jay London,
you're good for a while.
Um,
pig pen,
everyone's googling j London and no results found on last comic standing.
So he stuck his hand in my mouth and I was like,
this did not happen in my twenties and I,
and I'm thinking,
am I,
are we gagging me?
I've lost the plot at this point.
Did you ask them?
Right,
well,
I'm sitting there and I'm like,
just waiting for something that happened.
I can't wait.
I'm not going to talk about.
Um,
and so I'm sitting there and I'm like,
and then for a minute I was like,
maybe he lost his balance and he just had,
and he just
like had to commit to it because it'd be too weird to be like,
sorry.
And then I was like,
maybe he was worried I was going to speak or because I am one,
maybe he just wanted to stop me from talking.
I don't know what it was,
but this did not happen in my twenties and I was broke.
Well,
got spit on in the face.
Spit in the face.
That's dark.
Yes.
Was it a broke?
No,
actually yes.
Hm.
Maybe more wealthy than you.
Maybe.
Here's the thing.
Here's the thing about my,
my,
uh,
this nebulous wealth that I have.
Everyone thinks I have way more than I have and it's been in the press that I
have all this money.
So I think guys that do have more money than me think I have more money than
them,
which I started.
Yes,
I see.
So maybe it was [inaudible] he thought I had more than I have.
Yeah.
He wanted to go.
Just so you know,
bitch with the Tesla,
you think you're so cute with your TV shows.
I'm about to fucking just treat you like a Thai hooker.
There are people that like that though.
That's where it gets weird.
If you date someone who likes weird shit.
Yes.
And then you go to someone else.
I've had that recently where I dated,
I was in a relationship that was relatively sexually perverse and then dated
someone who was very not and I was like way overshot the mark.
I mean am I this?
I'm just fuck it.
Um,
I am going to be single forever after this bike goes.
I did have a guy one time cause here's what you do now.
I need more coffee.
Jesus Christ.
When you see this is too graphic,
I feel like I'm covering a lot of this stuff to that Neil degrasse Tyson and
covered on this podcast.
Are we being,
are we just talking about the moon landing?
Um,
you have to gag on Dick's now.
No,
you don't.
Yeah.
Well if you don't,
you will be,
uh,
exercise.
Yes,
you will be.
Your head will be pushed down.
Um,
yeah,
guys pushed your head down and you're like,
oh shit.
Okay,
this is happening.
I'm like,
I have a fucking,
I haven't Tesla two blocks away.
Why are you jamming my head on it?
And then so I just thought that's how you did it.
And then I dated this guy,
uh,
and I did that and he goes,
oh,
no,
no.
So embarrassing.
He goes,
he goes,
um,
I'm actually not turned on by girls hurting themselves.
And I was like,
Oh God,
I was so embarrassed because I remember like when 30 rock was going on,
I'd go out on a date with a girl and then like 30 minutes into the date she
starts talking about her boyfriend.
I,
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
She's like,
Oh,
I thought we were just going out for dinner on like friends.
And I'm like,
I'm like,
I asked you out,
it's Saturday night.
And I'm like,
oh,
I go to her,
like,
are you like,
are you,
are you cheating on your boyfriend?
And you know,
I didn't know many more like he is,
he got a town,
are you guys have an open relationship?
She's like,
no,
he's here.
I'm like,
well where is he
got the apartment?
I'm like,
well fucking go and hand.
What the fuck you doing over here with me?
You know how many times this happened?
That happened a few times where girls would like want to like go out with me
just to take pictures so they can tell their Facebook friends and oh,
so they became friends with you because you were on television.
Right,
exactly.
So that romance I think,
I think when that stuff was happening that's also,
I don't know.
I'm just guessing here.
I don't have the exact answers.
I'm just thinking out loud,
but I think that's maybe sort of around the same time when I started worrying
about like bloggers and shit,
like shitting on it.
You know,
my friend Eddie has this theory about bill Cosby about a bill Cosby when he
started doing that to women and he thinks that that might have been the similar
type of situation where these women wanted to be around him,
but they were turning him down and he started drugging them that he started
raping of,
yeah,
yeah.
Did that I just left.
Yeah.
You're much better man than him.
But you know what I mean?
Like that can happen where someone is attracted to you simply because you're a
famous person who think,
well,
hey,
this is a girl that I'm romantically interested in it.
I'd like to go anywhere.
Then you're at dinner,
what the fuck,
man.
So you're,
you're talking to this girl,
you go,
Hey,
do you want to go out to dinner?
And she's like,
yeah,
that sounds good.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then all of a sudden you were on a date.
It's just telling you about her boyfriend and Saturday,
it's 10 o'clock.
Yeah.
And you're thinking,
yeah,
look at you.
I'm
just going to get some all right.
And she's like,
yeah,
my boyfriend's waiting for me that she just casually mentioned him about
something.
Oh yeah,
my boyfriend said this or something.
I'm like,
Huh?
What?
Yeah.
And this happened more than once.
Gonna go into movies and is gonna you know,
take off and become this.
So she's fine either way but issue because do people want to see those movies
the same way they want to see those movies when she was smashing Alexis Davis
and armbarring Misha Tate knocking out Batchko Hey,
uh Dee Dee is there that same draw?
Well I'll say this,
I don't think people are going to Rhonda movies cause she's a phenomenal
actress.
Does that make sense?
Like,
I'm not going to see Ron's moocs.
You got to see her.
You got to see her act in this sheet is amazing.
She is because she's,
because she's supposedly the baddest woman on the planet now Holly Holm shut her
down.
Yeah.
So now Holly is thought to be the baddest woman on the planet,
correct?
Right.
Correct.
If,
unless she fights cyborg.
If they figured out a catch weight fight,
you know,
in,
in MMA,
that's really the big scary fight for her for sure.
You know?
And she said she would fight her.
Yeah,
she's,
she's fought at one 52 in boxing.
You know,
Holly Holm,
she's,
she's gangster.
But I mean,
I think other than w what would you do if you were,
if you were the promoter,
let me ask you this,
what would you do if I'm Dana White?
Yes.
Scrooge McDuck.
If I'm above scrooge McDuck Dana White.
Well,
I fire Reebok right now,
by the way.
I say scrooge McDuck ice crate.
Say Scrooge McDuck like three or four times a week now,
strictly because of you.
He sent me this text the other day with a picture of scrooge McDuck sitting on a
pile of gold and I was just laughing,
laughing.
I love that character.
The fight like you did with Chad and we got the biggest fight.
You no biggest fighter of all time.
Wild Shit.
But the thing is,
is if you look at the,
if,
if I'm a businessman,
I'm not,
not as much water as fun,
but a businessman,
Conor winning is the golden ticket button play too,
because Josie,
you know,
he's not even be around that much longer,
right?
But there's never been a guy like Conor before the UFC has been fine.
Like you don't need to know.
It's not necessarily the best thing.
[inaudible] Dana's still scrooge.
Mcduck I'm not saying son,
I'm not,
I'm not saying he goes broke,
but I don't even think it's just talking about the new heights.
I don't think so.
Look at this
after the backstroke through a sea of gold.
Like you love that guy.
I just never thought about it till you started bringing up scrooge McDuck I
never thought about that cartoon.
It's random as fuck.
Whatever.
You talk about money,
like I ain't scrooge McDuck don't likes treats.
That's right.
Scrooge McDuck yet a lot of money ball and son.